[Music]
all right welcome back to pack C's 2019
this is Lord sovereign from the iron
Lords podcast and Lords of gaming dotnet
I have the distinct pleasure to be here
with Chris Khalil Achmed the Cole
developers of swim sanity guys tell us a
little bit about your game as soon as
you walked by the game we said wait a
minute we got to see what this is so
please guys sure this is some sand it's
a four-player underwater shooter with a
question of competitive and cooperative
game modes we can play with or against
your friends we got eight game owns in
this five versus your deathmatch team
deathmatch capture the flag team capture
the flag and last move is standing it's
an elimination on the flip side of that
we got cooperative modes so we got a
full-blown campaign mode with boss
battles we also got a survival mode as
well we even have a third mode we have
an announced that today on top of all
that it's online and offline play so you
just gave me a mouthful there so tell me
how how big is his dev team is it just
you guys and how long have you guys been
working on this game
beautiful thing to hear man that's a
beautiful thing to hear so we've been
best friends since we were 7 years old I
had the fortunate experience of meeting
these guys when I was real young they've
grown up in the same bedroom all along
and yeah we've just really clicked we're
like a family out here doing this yeah
we decided we wanted to make games about
nine years ago it took us some time to
actually learn how to do what we were
doing built the POC over a couple of
years submitted that and then decided we
wanted to go full time with this so what
you're seeing today is closer to like
three years of work so how did you come
up the idea for swim sanity what did you
what sort of what's the impetus for it I
mean this started as a school project it
was actually start off this game called
swim say The Adventures of Obadiah the
scuba diver since this is a team they
told me that name wasn't going to fly so
he kept swim sanity it's actually
inspired by the old a Nintendo game
called an octopus where Mars go down to
the bottom of the ocean try to grab gold
and go back up to his boat while the Ox
was trying to grab him so I was like all
right cool I'm gonna add a jellyfish I'm
gonna add a seahorse I'm going to add a
swordfish and the game kind of took off
but not like in a small group this is my
brother's side and he's always been the
one who goes a lot extra than I do
it was like bro we got to make this
multiplayer we got to make it so it's on
consoles so we kind of started doing a
game development but we're pretty bad on
the art side and so we're like we gotta
find an artist so we actually connected
back with Chris after like not really
talking for a little while it's like
it's busy
and met him at the bank were like you
know we got to talk about something we
want to make a game and Chris I have no
an idea at the time he wasn't doing
digital art we're like if we can teach a
teaser software we're gonna learn how to
make games we're gonna make this happen
and over nine years just where we are
right now that's amazing man like when
you first look at the game immediately
it just looks like a multiplayer game so
you got I said full-on story mode
you've got bosses and all that sort of
stuff I'm gonna talk to Aquaman now tell
me a little bit about that yeah
absolutely so we have an adventure mode
we actually ran a private beta a couple
weeks ago we figured out our venture
mode just before players bill playing
but a lot of one player people kind of
came
like I want to try to meet this on my
own things like that so all the
experience can play single-player or
online so even if you actually at home
and just have a couple of feel to play
we also have box so you can play with AI
so we really want to make game no matter
if you have one two three four five
friends online close we want to make
every experiencing to play some sanity
that's the whole point of it in terms of
like power-ups and stuff like that like
how does the gameplay flow like it yeah
you get like a upgrades here to your
character stuff like that what do you do
players move us so move us our Apothic
hero
so you gets unleashed so when you
unleash some sanity you basically can
choose one unleashes in the game we deal
enough damage on your opponent's your
unleash bar is gonna fill up and then
you use your ultimate there so you could
turn to a shark have harpoons rain from
the sky so you have all these things
that you can unlock so we have 13
unleashes they can do so we're running
about six of our game right now in this
booth but when you go in the game and
collect more and you have all the
experience that you could unlock and you
can do it it is it a game you can play
couch co-op as well as its online
multiplayer what we were trying to bring
to the game right was like all the
classic features that we loved about 90s
videogames
we're 90s boys man we wanted to bring
that forward merge it with the modern
day technologies that we have and so
yeah whether you sit down again local or
online you're gonna be able to add a lot
of focus for sanity I tell you right now
guys your story mirrors our story we
grew up together loving video games we
decided that you know what let's have a
podcast let's talk about games and this
is where we are that's what we're doing
now just followed in our passion so us
guys if you have not seen swim sanity
and you're at PAX East come over here
and show these guys some love the game
looks amazing at first glance it looks
like just a small multiplayer game and
there's a whole heck of a lot more to it
so guys check out swim sanity thank you
so much guys